okay so some this some parameters here
okay so uh let's say you're going to get
ready to stab me okay
so right now you would have a marshal
advantage that
why okay so uh let's have you scoot back
a whole
step back to go okay you can change your
one okay all right so you would you
would picture doing what in iida I know
it's weird just do do it okay you you'd
have to take a lot of steps right to
start back out there okay and so you
have a marshall Advantage again why my
weap out okay so as you you go in a
little faster if you want and you can
see that it's time for me to get my
weapon out you see that actually no
Marshal advantage to you being out there
with your knife in your hand you see
that
okay your Marshall bandage
is life hand okay now if you understand
that where would you like to start up
close yeah up close somewhere where I
don't have time to get my nut out right
okay um and then if you watch this this
is the easy experiment so you don't have
to go from spe uh if I draw as you
attack at this point you see you go a
little faster go okay I can't get my
knife go I can't get my knife out
getting my knife out actually creates
the opening that he needs if you look at
it in terms of Yin and Y I'm going Yin
you see my arms are coming towards me
and then it's just here okay
and that happens when we're close like
this right even if I move he's going to
track you so you go and I try to move I
can't get the weapon out on time okay
got got that okay so uh what we have to
do is create a deployment space for the
weapon okay cuz right now you do have an
advantage okay uh meaning I'm not going
to
go and then try to do something like
that I might have to but I'd rather not
okay so what we do instead is deployment
space there's the range you get and then
the weapon comes out
okay so that's our drill here
boom I'm going to open it up because
you're a little more advanced you kind
of do whatever you want
okay what would you say what skills am I
using yeah so as I come in I'm going to
connect right and then there a
projection creates the deployment space
okay I'm not trying to
do this stuff you guys get
it it's just
out whatever I
touch I stick to Boom whatever I touch
you
see I stick to boom and then projector
create the deployment
space okay let's try Okay so uh when he
attacks let's see how much penetration
you would actually have
you see and that's
realistic so he's not just kissing me
here you see that
difference that I would probably let
that stab me if it meant that I I could
come here and go okay it's probably my
garment is going to stop that it's not
they're not laser they're not
lightsabers garments have an effect on
them okay so when he does his his thing
you can see he would have the full 6 in
which is fighting knife length because
it hits organs okay it's going to hit
organs for sure okay when he does his
thrust
okay um the other thing is to note is
you have to still keep in mind that this
is going to spiral rotate at that 90°
fluctuation okay so you cannot stay on
the line and then see
something okay you get that that's
you're going to
move and keep this thing rotating
because it's a one step it's not going
to be like when we're uh sparring you
get it but it still is going to use the
same thing I'm going to come
to
out off the line never on the line
off the line
boom whichever way cuz you can mix it up
right off the
line off the line every time you got to
get off the line okay and then towards
that end then you have to read the body
so you and to read the body means to
move to start moving at
intention meaning I don't wait until I
see it
I'm already moving I know that I know
it's that side you see when he when he
carried it low like that and it comes
out it's probably going to be that it's
not going to be that do you get it so I
kind of play the odds
there but in a way let's say you were
going to come with that belly slash it's
still there do you see because I'm
combining my angle of deflection with my
angle of deviation
okay um so you got to move that
intention you get it and create your
traps across what he's
doing on his angle of attack so for
example I don't do do something other
than the low thrust okay so we go and
you can
see that my hands are in a place where
his weapon is going to touch my trap do
you see that I don't I'm not going like
that my hands stay inside my outer rib I
move my body heel touch me and then
that's what I
project you guys it's different than
this didn't move at all and I'm trying
to touch his weapon i instead in here
you see he touches me and and I project
when he touches me okay and you can mix
it up boom
[Music]
boom that was a good
example that was a good
example the elbow was here right
I felt him thought he was going high but
he started to go low and so the elbow
stays there the Trap stays there and
then you have that
okay so move that
intention let him hit your trap don't
take your hands out of your outer rim
okay very anchored and compact okay
we'll still do the deployment thing go
all right so when I
go I'm going to take him into the
kazushi cavern which means I have to
seize his Center so I'm not here and
then I'm just
pushing there there there is
a seizure of the that's not how he he
goes right you know what I mean you can
you can you can feel it okay sees the
center that's why I can project this
Center so if we go back on that
hand we're here I see that's what's
moving him You' see and this
hand did not have to go like
that this
hand can stay there and get the
projection making it more ready to
draw but more importantly you have the
center okay we go boom Center all the
time boom Center all the
time Center all the
okay all right so some things that are
happening why why you want to seize the
center so if I don't seize his Center
then he has his balance he doesn't have
to worry about it and that's when the
arm can go in and out you see boom boom
he can keep stabing so keep doing this
stuff right you get I never have my
Center so that's why on the first one I
want to capture this you see that you
guys get that and so even if I got out
of the
way I wouldn't have an athlete Center
because they they don't they don't fall
for that stuff do you get it he he would
just miss and then in comes again you
see what you'll have to do at contact is
touch his Center Now understand though
it's just a force it's not
magic you don't go oh what's happening
to me and you stay like that you get
it's just a force so when I have a
center what do you want to do he wants
to free his Center you see so here here
was the center you see you see how it's
you feel that on your body yeah so what
he's going to do it's here's the
connection point so he cleared it boom
now he has his Center again do do you
see that and now he can move his arm as
many fast as he wants okay do do you
guys understand that okay but what do he
have to do to free his Center go clear
and what's he not doing in that moment
attack attacking me do you see that okay
so I want him to however he wants you
see it's fine that's our drill for the
UK he clears it however he wants he
comes in with whatever he wants he has
to clear it okay you didn't clear the
other
hand I'll just look yep good okay and
this is just like this game you see I I
I have a center he's going to clear it
however he can till he can get in do you
get
it you can clear your
center with boom I can go around it so
here we go I did a a non-c contention do
you see he he has me there and go ahead
and use it you see he's got my Center
okay so I go around the arm you see this
arm you got to come over here
camera here's his here's his adhes
adhesion point so you'll see that he can
he's got my center and right when I feel
him pull my Center I let go and there's
there would be my movement you
see but as I told you on the last you
were
drilling that's why don't have only the
knife hand on the center
you see
so yeah you were using this hand don't
use this hand yet you just were touching
like a block but you don't have my
Center in that hand here is where you
had your seizure go ahead and seizure
there it is okay you can see my body go
okay and then I yield and I get you
but if you have my Center here as well
so let's see if you do there it is right
there okay and so when you feel me going
around you still have that
the center got it so both
hands both hands have to have it okay
both hands have to have it not just the
knife hand this one is
just a defensive angle both hands have
to
have so then in this drill he goes He
freeze himself boom that's all we want I
want him to refine his Center you didn't
get that hand
out yep good do it
again now time a
little here's how you can do it
too this one you're doing is you're
coming around you're yielding coming
around another one you can do where
where are you going you see
if I instead of
resisting and I move with you it's
gone you see so I can take my center
right instead of contesting what you're
doing here that's what opens me up to
the seizure as you're moving I move and
I'm so I don't only have to come
around right I can yield my body and
I'll get it and of course you could have
your trap and clears that you were doing
okay any of those work I'm probably more
interested in that you move your
Center Just sh to shut it off like that
okay but in either
way the attack the counter The
Continuous attack gets interrupted okay
all right so we're working on UK skill
go all right so uh we we had a little
discussion here we have different levels
on the map today and so I want to do
something a little we we did some
Advanced Training yesterday for ronin's
level and we're doing it again today and
so some of my less skilled levels are
like I just can't get this going and the
reason why is that this is the same uh
mechanics right that we do in drill one
or two of the cou cultivation set it's
it's the same or drill one or two of the
IE cultivation set however those are
controlled environments and this is a a
live environment and so what happens is
that within the live environment uh the
ego tripartite mind is more stimulated
because it has more of a a will to uh
Will To Power in it and when we have
that will to power uh spiritually
psychologically uh we're going to have
more self- attachment when we have more
self- attachment we can't let the the
young aspect doesn't want to go through
we contest it and we start resorting to
external things and then we can't do the
drill it's just too fast okay to do it
um the whole point of the internal stuff
is this mid-range grappling as you see
uh we're kind of hanging out in this
area right is this area here where you
do mid-range grappling all right if I
for example if he has his knife out okay
and he go he goes and I go to here
what's he going to
do do you see I you you picture in your
head you're going to pick them up and
you're going to slam them but it's done
right and then in that I can't get my
knife either so weapons fighting uses uh
a lot of mid-range so the same thing um
if he comes let's say he does a an arm
pull
right and he goes to take the back boom
right and then I'm over here see the I
cut and the I cut he can't control my
ability to have the weapon and so the
mid-range grapplings is where you you're
dealing with can I deploy my weapon can
I retain my weapon and same with the
other guy okay and so we're doing
mid-range grappling well mid-range
grappling requires the internal aspects
uh because it's so fast right and the
way you're doing this is if I seiz your
Center you're going to have to un you're
going to have to free your Center in
order to continue your assault do do you
get that and it's not as easy as we
think it is okay so let's let's go on
what I would like to see now is I'll be
the
attacker we know what we're trying to do
and there's no reason why I should get
uh triggered into my Will To Power as
I'm trying to do my things so as I go do
you see how I shut that off right away
you're pulling right now so I would keep
moving do you get it I feel I felt as I
come in I felt my center and I can move
with it so I go one feel it and I'm
moving it you see how effortlessy it is
you see I don't have to
go and go back to external okay I'm
shutting
off the internal I'm sorry yeah the
internal on you and then I could take my
internal back to you you see and then
get my advantage so i' would like to see
your
ability to be more calm on that side it
doesn't it doesn't require anything like
that it's just it's on it's off
boom no you
should take it yeah you're moving and
saying you didn't have the ground
yep and so what are you noticing that
you're getting
now yes you see it's very important
okay
yep but it came from me increasing my
attack skill
yes I don't want to go here like that
ground don't twist your
your come
on find it again
okay okay
so what we're doing there at the end is
he
freeze and I follow here again you get
it so you free it and I follow it in
here again boom
free bre good
three yes
good and here is where you're going to
see your
Keyon
boom
bo you're not going to see it on the
first one you're not going to see it
here you're going to see it when you
freeze is where it's going to
be three
right if he doesn't free you're going to
project so he has to free
okay let's see if we can get there yes
I don't know what the hell that
was
sees always seize first don't try for
the technique seese let him unseize and
then he'll attack and the technique will
be there sees
unse yes
again
continue nope go back you're fighting
the knife seize the
center he un
seizes
good good
Seas un seiz good
[Music]
good no Noe nope sees you can see he
just he's pretty free okay get his
Center make him
uncomfortable seize there it is there it
is there it is you see
that you got to seiz it's just like in
it's just like in weapons work okay so
remember in weapons work your your
counter is entirely dependent on how
much you fulfilled your preceding
assault you you Hass your makos and
you're not going to be there for harai
do do you get do you guys understand
that okay you have to do your full
seizure so that he fully un seizes and
now he's going to move in now you're in
your kihon waza Tactical Spectrum okay
get the seizure first here we
go sees there he goes good yes then it's
effortless
sees there it is
yep no no look how much balance he has
so for examp so you didn't is there so
stay there go ahead and Reet your grip
okay now uh don't hurt him Andrew but
just pull your elbow back towards your
Center do you see and you're not going
to be able to stop that okay let's try
it
again follow the trapping rules he runs
into your trap sees then you
wait so you could do shho nag after at
that opening but first it has to start
with the seizure
sees much
better SE yep yep good all right cycle
through okay so uh this is this is where
the skill comes in uh and so I've asking
the
other the more advanced Desi on the mat
to see if they can deduce what's going
on okay so um I'm going to say
say there's no seizure because remember
this tactical sequence requires the UK
Center to be seized then to counter the
seizure and then that's where you would
start seeing the Tactical spectrum of
kihon Wasa okay so we could either pose
this question is there a seizure or if
not when is there a seizure okay so here
we go
and uh whenever whenever you guys have
it the answer you can just take a stab
at
it still no Ronin not even I come in for
this second attack
nope nope that's not where there's
something that's okay so you got a
little projected there at the end do you
see that so clearly she has the
Center at
where at the at projection do you see
that okay and um go down your skill tree
which is easier to get out of the two
internals Co C projection is easier to
get than the adhesion the II do you see
okay so that's your clue so here we go
and let's see
so when the forces are sufficiently high
she can generate the adhesion with when
it's not the matching of the Y values
when it's that she can generate a
greater y value to initiate the
projection uh I'm going to say no okay
so let's say I go here and do I have
your sent no no but am I blocking your
path of action yeah yes okay so now all
he has to do is an arm swing and I I'm
dead Okay so same same thing you do I
have your Center okay you see and which
force has your
Center okay yes do you see that so if if
I work my C you and you start here and
then now you have it you do but not
going to get there because you're
deflecting a fighter they're just going
to go around the external deflections do
you see that but if on contact you're
here you see I haven't projected
yet and so that's what he's spraying the
center you see you get it and that's the
problem you just have an external
deflection and you're waiting to be able
to push into his Center but by that time
he's already gone around your external
defenses okay and what we want is
Boom okay we want the I adhesion uh
that's the that's the seizure okay this
is this is a projection of the center
this is a seizure of the center seizure
of the center okay got it um I use that
word instead but you could think of it
as once's a pushing of the center once's
a pulling of the center okay I like
seizure better though try